Excusez-moi madame, désolée de vous déranger, on est étudiante en fait à la
fac, on fait une étude sur le cinéma. On voulait savoir si c'était possible de vous poser
quelques questions, ça prend vraiment deux petites minutes maximum.
Quel film vous venez de voir ? Toilite. D'accord. Est-ce que ça vous a plu ?
Oui, c'était très bien. C'est quoi qui vous a plu dans le film ?
Tout, qui est bien aimé. Le jeu des acteurs, le scénario. Vous aviez déjà vu les précédents ?
J'en ai vu un que le premier, alors c'est sûr. Il m'a mangé un morceau, mais non, je trouvais ça pas mal.
Mieux que le premier, ça bougeait plus. Que diriez-vous à quelqu'un pour le convaincre
justement d'aller voir ce film ? C'est pas évident. Il faut vraiment aimer
déjà un peu le fantastique. C'est pas non plus un film qui fait très très peur,
c'est pour les jeunes, plutôt pour les jeunes, pour les ados je dirais.
C'est un film pour ados. Est-ce que vous pouvez me raconter dans les grandes lignes bien sûr
l'histoire du film ? C'est une histoire d'amour entre une humaine qu'ils appellent
et puis un vampire. C'est une grande ligne. Quand j'ai pas vu les deux du milieu,
il me manque un morceau. Là, apparemment, ils se sont mariés, ils ont eu un bébé et puis
c'est un peu un truc à l'odorose. Pour moi, c'est comme ces romancés, comme les histoires
pour les petits. Ça va être une belle histoire d'amour qui finit bien.
D'accord. Est-ce que vous aimez bien ce cinéma ? Je viens pas souvent d'ailleurs. Je viens une fois
depuis peut-être une dizaine d'années. Et en règle générale, vous aimez bien le cinéma ?
Oui. Vous y allez régulièrement ? On va à Saran en général. On est mieux par rapport aux horaires.
Oui, bien sûr. Alors je vais terminer avec trois petites questions. Je vais vous demander votre âge,
si vous voulez bien. J'ai 44 ans. D'accord. Votre profession ?
Secrétaire. D'accord. Et vous habitez où ?
A Cléris-Saint-André. D'accord. Alors en fait, cet enregistrement, il va nous servir parce qu'on
dresse le portrait sonore de la ville d'Orléans en 2011 et on voulait savoir si on pouvait utiliser
cet enregistrement. C'est totalement anonyme ? Oui. Oui ? Vous voulez bien ? D'accord. Bonne
journée. Merci beaucoup. Bonne soirée.